so for the second topic I want to talk
about existing regulation and in order
to talk about how existing regulations
in the US which by the way have
generally strong analogues globally so
I'm gonna talk mostly about US law but
there's very similar laws in at least
the European Union and in many other
developed countries but in order to talk
about this existing regulation we need
to talk a little bit about which
technologies were even talking about
because different technologies are going
to be regulated differently because
they'll either fit or not fit into the
definitions of a regulated entity
depending on how they're built so that
means talking about permissioned versus
permissionless crypto currencies and
backed stable coin type currencies
versus commodity money digital
currencies and I would be remiss to not
bring up the elephant in the room which
is this conversation had reached a kind
of plateau of agencies that had a piece
of jurisdiction here had established
their policies pretty clearly so as I
said coin centers been doing the work
we've been doing now for five years
whether it's anti-money laundering law
enforced by FinCEN which is a division
of treasury whether it's securities laws
enforced by the SEC whether it's money
transmission laws which is
state-by-state a lot of things had
reached a point of stability and
actually a good policy outcome when
Facebook decided to launch Libre there
was suddenly a massive amount of renewed
interest in digital currencies and most
regulators haven't necessarily changed
their opinions but it's worth noting
that Congress has become extremely
interested in this technology now and so
members of the House in the Senate who
we hadn't even had any you know
interaction with their staffs before
we're suddenly asking about crypto
currency or digital currency so then
this is all just happened over the last
summer so these topics are now very hot
again in DC
take a picture of you next to there in
Markuson you're studying oh you're gonna
send it to David Marcus I'm sorry and by
the way I think David Marcus did an
incredible job in the hearing I am
actually amazed that someone could sit
through that much and remain so poised
and his answers were by and large very
good but anyway so the foundational
difference between Bitcoin and Libre is
one of permission versus permissionless
we call Bitcoin a permissionless network
I'll explain what I mean by that I hope
it's not a loaded or debatable term but
I'm open to being criticized and Libre
is a permission network so basically
this is how we sometimes explain you
know Bitcoin which is you want PayPal
without PayPal you want a group of sort
of you know computers on the internet to
do all the things that PayPal did user
onboarding record-keeping management you
know and to do it in a way that you
don't have to trust any one of these
participants and that this set you know
I've only drawn four or five six seven
is actually like an open set it could be
in theory much larger than seven there's
no legal or identification type barrier
to joining this set there's all you have
to do is be able to calculate sha-256
really fast because you're looking for
collisions effectively and we're not
looking for collisions you're looking
for hashes with sufficient zeros at the
front and you need to validate digital
signatures and those are both things
that commodity hardware can do and the
software to do that in the way Bitcoin
wants you to do that is open source so
free and open software a computer now to
verify signatures as I said commonly
available desktop they probably do that
it would take a while for the whole box
train in order to actually add blocks so
this is like the read from the
blockchain bury hit entry and this is
the right to the blockchain actually
right the block bear
at entry you need purpose-made hardware
you need a six at this point but they
are available it's not like there's one
company alone that makes them and it's
not like they're not available on you
know multiple different markets so this
is what we mean by permissionless free
software and commodity hardware and this
could get better
I don't think permissionless is
necessarily like a binary term it'd be
great if we could decentralize mining
more so that really anybody with a
laptop at home can participate fully in
the protocol and maybe proof of stake
but even then you've got an obvious
barrier because you need to be rich in
order to take enough so but you know
questions no no no I'm saying prove
mistake might make things a little bit
better than proof of work but even with
proof mistake you'll still need to have
a lot to stake so how much can you
really participate unless you're rich at
this point you have to be rich to
participate fully in these protocols but
what you're doing is all on an open
network and it's effectively audited by
a bunch of people in plain sight so
hopefully that kind of centralization is
somewhat mollified by the fact that it's
open but we could say the same thing
about permission validators as well if
what they're doing is out in the open
anyway by permissioned all i mean is you
need software and hardware to
participate but you also need
authorization from an organizing
authority that's like a legally
cognizable thing in the case of Libre
it's the Liebherr Association which is a
non-profit that's going to be
incorporated in Geneva might already be
incorporated in Geneva I don't know and
so here you go the Libre Association
will launch at some point with a number
of members this is what they've
announced so far I think it's like 28 so
far including themselves or including
Facebook which is maker of the calibra
wallet and they plan to launch with a
hundred so they'll they'll have to get
more members so again the limit of
participation Bitcoin yeah you gotta buy
a bunch of this stuff and improve
mistake systems you've got to actually
have a bunch of the coin but the limit
of participation here is you have to get
a token if you will an authorization of
some sort to participate on the
blockchain from the association that
manages the blockchain and then the
question of stable versus commodity like
digital assets Bitcoin is valuable
because of scarcity there's just only so
much Bitcoin described on the Bitcoin
blockchain at this moment it's like 17
million units I think and the protocol
suggests that they'll only ever be 21
million if everybody who ran Bitcoin
software decided that number should
change it would change so there's an
artificial 'ti to the scarcity but the
idea that everyone's gonna suddenly hurt
their own interests and change that
number is something that's sticky that
means that supply is generally stuck and
if there's positive demand the
intersection of the demand curve and the
supply curve will set the price and
that's all that sets the price which
means if demand shifts wildly and supply
can't adjust it'll be very volatile and
we've seen that with Bitcoin Libre and
with other stable coins the intent is
for each unit to be backed by something
if you're familiar with tether or USD C
and there's several other stable coins
the original intent was often there'll
be one unit of national currency for
every unit of the stable coin tether
used to say we have one dollar for every
tether the company that issues tether
now says that it's a bundle of assets
including shares of stock in their
exchange and some other you know things
that are of questionable value so tether
has maybe become untethered I don't know
us DC or Gemini dollars which is the
Winklevoss twins stable coin project for
Gemini as an example they're in New York
trust company and they claim that in
their legally incorporated trust that's
regulated in New York State they'll have
one dollar for every Gemini dollar and
so they control the issuance of the
token and we trust them or we don't that
the only issue with token if they get a
dollar in the trust
reduce the money supply although they
can destroy so you can destroy units if
it depends on the architecture of what
you're building but even if what you're
building is something like an ER C 20
token on top of aetherium you could
always burn it you buy it back from
somebody so you have to give up a dollar
buy it back and then burn it you send it
to an address that has no possible or as
likely no possible private key that
could allow it to be spent in the future
sufficiently non-random public key that
it would be impossible to think that
someone actually generated the private
key to that public key scarcity here is
is virtually right this is yes can
decide to change the number absolutely
just like a different governance decide
to change the number of dollars I mean a
governing body it's not the majority of
miners though necessarily it's it's it's
it's just the protocol so interesting so
I suppose the you can keep your you love
it you know 21 million
well you'd fork what would happen would
be a fork and you and anyone who goes
with you would still have 21 million
right so users and people who hold a lot
users and people who hold a lot who may
not be miners could say well we're not
going to change our software which means
their software would now be running
incompatible with the miners which means
oh yeah yeah I'm just saying it's a
bigger set than miners it's a set of all
users because if anyone maintains a
client whether it's mining or not that
is incompatible with what the miners
have decided to do it will build its own
peer-to-peer network if there's a
sufficient number of them they may not
be miners they may just be users and
then
ultimately there'll be two assets
assuming there's some critical number on
both sides of the fork and there could
not be so yes if everyone went to the
same restaurant in the same night
there'd be chaos but they don't so if
there's two forks
they'll potentially be markets in each
as we have seen with things like
aetherium in aetherium classic and
Bitcoin in several questionable Forks
and then the market will set a price and
and that's ultimately the thing that
really drives this so yeah I could try
and convince a bunch of miners to go
around and double the amount of Bitcoin
in circulation and we could try and
convince the exchanges to list our thing
in addition to people who don't want
that change and then what would the
market do with that thing I'm just
saying it's a larger problem set than
the idea that the miners can
unilaterally just change well the
majority doesn't have to take the
longest this is this is not a fork in
that there are two long chains and we
haven't figure out which is the longest
yet this is a fork where in the two
consent the consensus rules of each
protocol or irreconcilable so they don't
even talk to each other anymore and
something like changing the ultimate
distribution of pick line within the
system would be would violate those
consensus rules just as we don't
basically be a whole new cryptocurrency
just as we don't think that because and
that's what that's that's what these
Forks ultimately are I mean Declan cash
is a brand-new cryptocurrency that
shares its blockchain up to the fork
with
and the proof of works of securing the
Bitcoin cash blockchain is tiny compared
to the proof of work securing the
Bitcoin blockchain so it's not the
longest chain and yet a bunch of people
choose to run software that follows
those consensus rules and maintains that
as a as another network ultimately it's
always the demand and supply like any
object that has value has to be finite
cars yes yes that's right right and so
again I mean Bitcoin is valuable because
it's very difficult to change the supply
not because it's impossible because it's
difficult and Libra or USD see the
supply is easily changed by design
because a company wants to have the
power or a group want to have the power
to change the supply to adjust to shifts
in demand and because the product
they're putting out in the world is not
intended to be a commodity currency it's
intended to be one that is always backed
by real assets rather than just
something that's arbitrarily scarce
because of a protocol that people find
difficult to break thank thank you for
pointing that out because I normally get
to that with this slide but we went in
two different directions so Libra is not
like us DC or Gemini that I was
describing earlier where there's in
theory one dollar for every Libra in
circulation the white paper and so Libra
is not even running yet but the white
paper describes a system wherein there
will be a bundle of assets that are held
by the Libra association or its partners
and those will be a variety of national
currencies like the dollar in the euro
and I think the yen and also low-risk
government debt so like Treasury bonds
and things like that and so one Libra
will represent one fractional interest
in that bundle of things so not exactly
one dollar 0.7 of a dollar 0.2 of a euro
point
one of government bonds and things like
that is that the stability is not they
decree is just by the locality mobility
with you of having a non
fractional-reserve yes
but the association is allowed with a
two-thirds vote to change the
composition of the reserve to include
new assets or remove assets from that
reserve so my majority vote to change
don't like the two-thirds choice we can
you know for Claybrook the same tech
market
I disagree cuz nothing backs Bitcoin
it's backed by nothing
whereas Libre has backing well I mean do
miners hold dollars or gold in relation
to the amount of bitcoins they mine they
don't have to they they've made no
contractual promise or legal promise to
hold that wealth in relation to the
bitcoins that they mined they can
alienate it from themselves whereas the
Liebherr association and gemini and the
other folks making stable coins have
made a societal contractual promise to
always have sufficient assets on hand
such that if someone comes to them with
a libra or a gemini dollar they can give
them the equivalent of the reserve III
mean I take it no I know you're not
arguing that but you said there's no
difference there is a difference in that
fit coin we're changing the policy so
use this use example say Libra could
change you know two thirds of the libras
you could say let's now change the
daughter to be in 0.87 0.7 you know
obviously the users I'll take your
stance I'm not making look good then say
you know that fork of Libra I'd like to
have a 0.7 dollar so I think I see where
we're disagreeing and it's maybe not a
disagreement but I might be wrong I'm
not making a normative argument that one
of these is better than the other I'm
just making an argument that
with Bitcoin there's nothing backing it
it's it's it's numbers on the blockchain
of a certain size and with Libra or
Gemini it's also numbers on a blockchain
but they're making promises to the
public that there will be some
correlated asset that they will secure
that will make that a non arbitrary
number that will make that a number that
has real assets backing it all I'm
saying is that Libra is backed Bitcoin
is not now
then you're getting the question of
value okay then why is Bitcoin valuable
if it's not backed by anything and the
only possible answer is because the
market judges that there's some at least
temporary limit on its scarcity because
if there wasn't why are people trading
it are they irrational I mean maybe you
could say that markets are just fully
irrational and I wouldn't necessarily
disagree with you when it comes to the
cryptocurrency prices I think they're
mostly garbage and that's why I don't
advocate that anyone invest in this
stuff at least not more than you're
willing to lose because this is all
crazy technology anyway so there's a
implicit assumption you can read in the
markets that people don't think the 21
number is changing anytime soon because
if they did you know it's silly so
that's all I mean by scarcity it is not
the scarcity of gold although frankly
the scarcity of gold could be put in
doubt Elon could go like grab one of
those gold asteroids and bring it in and
then we're screwed right or
nanotechnology I don't know you know
these are just assumptions made by
rational economic actors in the economy
and the assumptions made by rational
economic actors in the economy or that
Bitcoin only has seventeen million in
circulation right now and we'll probably
only have 21 million ever that could be
totally wrong and the assumption that
rationally can economically is in the
economy are making with respect to Libra
is that the Liebherr Association holds
one to one a reserve of which they
described which is the number of dollars
euros yen and other things that they
said would be proportional to a sheriff
I mean yes but you cannot as a US
citizen or a foreigner or anyone go to
the Central Bank and say I don't want
this dollar anymore I want the real
assets that pack it up they're not going
to give you anything they used to this
was what the gold standard was but would
it be better yeah it would ruin it would
wrap it and it would rapidly destroy all
of our macroeconomic policies or fun at
least I'm having fun anyway oh this is
about the scarcity who is going to see
the production will some Marco sample
they will see on my transaction it's a
good question so as described the Libre
protocol privacy wise looks a lot like
Bitcoin we're in anybody can generate
yes but not just Mark Zuckerberg anyone
it's very public now Facebook will make
the calibra wallet which will be how I
think most people at least at first will
interact with the Libre protocol because
it'll be the wallet made by Facebook
that baked into whatsapp and the other
apps that they hope to have Libre
trading on and they'll have certain
proprietary information about who's
using that calibra wallet which they can
then match to the public information on
the blockchain so they'll have a better
a better view but no better view
Libra necessarily then like a very large
exchange on Bitcoin like coinbase has
both the people who are buying Bitcoin
on their platform and the public
information on the on the blockchain
[Music]
motivation I I'm sure I I guess I I
don't I don't I don't I wouldn't presume
what their motivations are but about
privacy about whether Libra is so so I
wouldn't be ready to just say that it it
just recreates WeChat and Ali pay
because it's still in some ways
censorship resistant because you would
have to convince all the members of the
Liebherr Association to block a
transaction rather than just having one
entity like WeChat capable of blocking a
transaction anyway this is a this is
probably a more in-depth discussion so
Gold baskets let's let's get away from
economics which is kind of like rival
religions fighting it's not really a
science
I shouldn't criticize I don't know I'm
I'm trained as a lawyer I'm not an
economist but yeah anyway regulations do
apply to this technology a lot of people
publish articles less so lately but
still sometimes that say like Bitcoin
the unregulated cryptocurrency the fact
of the matter is lots of regulations
actually apply to Bitcoin or Gemini
dollars or any kind of those regulations
are broadly speaking anti money
laundering regulations consumer
protection regulations and investor
protection regulations and within this
question of who's the investor
protection regulator and what are the
investor protection regulations there's
a central question in the US about
whether it's the SEC which is the
regulator of securities a certain type
of investment versus the CFTC the
Commodity Futures Trading Commission
which is the regulator of commodities
derivatives markets they don't actually
regulate markets for corn which is a
commodity but they do regulate
derivatives markets where people trade
futures or swaps where the underlying
value in the contract is some corn to be
delivered in the future so I'll go into
some more depth anti money laundering
regulations what do they look like well
first of all in the u.s. they're federal
regulations so it's the federal
government not the local state
governments that do it and in the EU for
example it's something that is done
through directive so all EU member
states have to basically have the same
AML policy as other member states and
the directives come from the EU and then
in other countries it's I mean the
federal provincial distinction it's
almost always done at the federal level
at the top level of government not
through subsidiary governments it tends
to be a registration type regime wherein
if you qualify as someone who
has to do anti money laundering things
and I'll describe those in a second you
have to register with the authority you
can't just be in this line of business
and not check in with the federal
government you have to register so they
know who you are and they can then know
whether you're doing these things or not
and what are you doing you're basically
doing surveillance for the government
and that's almost an inflammatory way of
putting it
because AML is a little bit of a
euphemism anti money laundering
like how can you be against anti money
laundering are you Pro money laundering
but AML it's not anti-money laundering
it's we want to collect a lot of
information about financial transactions
in the economy and use that information
to stop money laundering it is a
surveillance regime at heart financial
institutions need to know their
customers need to know sometimes who
their customers are paying and if their
customers are paying the wrong people
need to stop their customers from paying
them need to report that information to
the federal government and there are
very harsh penalties obviously that that
consumer protection in the US for crypto
currencies there's no federal consumer
protection regulation it's kind of
strange this is a these things are
global by default they can trade
anywhere around the world and yet we
don't even regulate them at the national
level we regulate them at the state
level for protecting consumers from
harms ms it's a very bad policy and in
the EU to give some more international
color there isn't really much consumer
protection at all at the moment these
things aren't really regulated as as
financial institutions for consumer
protection policies in the US it's a
state-by-state licensing regime which
means if you qualify as someone who's
supposed to do consumer protection for
crypto currencies and I'll get into who
that might be in a second its exchanges
is the giveaway you need to get a
license from every state where you have
customers which means you have to get a
license from 53 states and territories
just to hold other people's bitcoins in
the US unless you geofence and don't
accept customers from
the states where you don't have licenses
what is it what are your obligations
this is not a surveillance regime this
is different this is not a ml this is
consumer protection you need to do a lot
of things like sometimes they want your
fingerprints to know that you're not a
criminal if you're running this business
holding people's bitcoins or what have
you you also are going to have to like
post a bond to prove that you have some
sufficient reserves to wind down if you
were hacked or went out of business and
maybe a minimum capitalization so you
have to be a big enough company to do
this you can't just be someone who like
has no assets and decided to hold a
bunch of people's Bitcoin and said trust
me and this also has harsh penalties if
you failed a license which is
interesting and the harsh penalties are
enforced by the federal government
weirdly if you are transmitting money
without a license at the state the
federal government can arrest you for
being an unlicensed money transmitter
this is actually how they sort of
enforce a lot of anti money laundering
law is by charging you not for money
laundry where you have to prove that
they knew they were laundering money but
just charge you as someone who was
moving money and wasn't licensed in the
state because to prove that you just
need to show that they never got the
license whereas to prove money
laundering you have to prove that they
actually knew that the money they were
moving was proceeds of a crime in
Alabama for example you can get licensed
as a money transmitter by posting a
$5,000 bond generally irrespective of
how much money you move for people which
is ridiculous
whereas if you want to be a bank you're
going to get chartered as a bank and
you're going to have to have you know
reserve requirements and much more
strict audits and a lot more regulation
now there might be a reasonable
trade-off here because banks don't just
hold people's money they lend it out and
in theory a money transmitter is never
lending they're just always holding
one-for-one you give money to Western
Union to PayPal they're not supposed to
be fractional reserve they're supposed
to just be holding it and then giving it
to the person who told them to go so
lower risk profile maybe explains the
lower level of regulation but at the
same time the fact that PayPal can be
licensed to transmit money in in Alabama
by posting a $5,000 bond somehow seems
still insufficient but there are other
states like California where you need to
post millions of dollars in collateral
basically to do that so it's just a mess
because it's a state-by-state approach
so finally investor protection law which
also applies to crypto currencies it is
both federal and state by state in the
US which means it's extremely
complicated its permission based if it's
securities regulation in other words
you're just not allowed to trade in
securities as a going concern without
basically getting a permission from the
SEC you need to be a national securities
exchange or an ATS if you want to issue
a security and this is where maybe we're
talking about other types of pearce
persons being regulated in this space
not just people holding people's digital
currencies but people who issue them if
you're issuing a security you have to
effectively get permission from the SEC
for doing a public offering an IPO which
means filing an s-1 and let's see SEC vs
CFTC jurisdiction in crypto currencies
is very unclear and the reason for this
is that some crypto currencies seem to
fit the definition of a security and
some don't and the SEC has preeminent
jurisdiction over everything that is a
security and the CFTC has jurisdiction
over everything that's a commodity but
commodity is drafted so broadly that
basically if you fall out of securities
you're gonna fall into commodities so
that's the division of labor there but
exactly when something is or isn't a
security as I'll get to in a second is
vague say the least
that's not really law that's people
interpreting the the case law about
securities and saying because people are
using this asset for things not as an
investment it doesn't fit the definition
of security in law but there's never
been a law passed or a regulation made
that has defined the term utility token
as something distinct in fact it's sort
of just people using a somewhat lazy
shorthand for describing asset that's
sufficiently useful that it doesn't seem
to be a security under the relevant
four-part test yes and so are currencies
some people think that currency is a
category here that's distinct these are
all overlapping and the main one that
matters from a who is the regulator on
point here is whether you qualify as a
security and then everything else is
generally a commodity so as I said the
SEC regulates both promoters and issuers
as well as the markets the CFTC only
regulates derivatives markets they don't
regulate the spot market they don't
regulate coinbase for example where
people are just trading a Bitcoin for an
ether if those are both commodities they
would not they would still not regulate
that even though those are both
commodities where they would regulate is
when the chicago board of trade or CBOE
are making markets in commodities
futures so derivatives contracts where
the underlying is the commodity that's
what they regulate and they don't
regulate promoters or issuers because
classically and appropriately
there's no issuer of gold there are just
gold miners in the world there are
people selling gold no one is the issuer
of gold
whereas
security Steve Jobs is the issuer of a
share of Apple stock so this is where
you can see the division between
commodities inside you're just kind of
like they're totally right you're
totally right it's a mess because miners
in Bitcoin are doing something that's
kind of like gold mining but also kind
of not they're also part of this sort of
social construct that by virtue of what
it's decided in an organic matter has
set the amount so it's a mess reasons
these are hard questions to grapple with
and interestingly there really haven't
been this kind of hard question to
grapple with before cuz it used to be
like yeah that's some corn that's not a
share of Monsanto whereas Bitcoin yeah
it's kind of a security but who's the
one who's really legally responsible is
it all the miners together is it all the
people who is that the people who wrote
the software who is it
[Laughter]
fortunately we have three cases on it no
I'm kidding
no this that question might be
determined in ten years if you have a
utility token which again as I said is
not a real legal thing it's just
somebody's shorthand for a token I don't
think fits the definition of security
and you use this utility token to do
proof of stake so it's part of a proof
mistake network if you stake it you earn
returns which may be because it's
changed in a way now it's not just
something that is being used it's
something that earns disbursement nobody
knows and it's going to be awhile
because this will have to shuffle out in
courts right so you're trying to you're
trying to reason by analogy it's so
different though it's it's not like you
have corn and you've lent it to someone
else and therefore it it's just it's
part of a process that secures the
network and then there's fees from
people using the network and you get
them because you stake it I don't think
there's anything quite like it but it
definitely does mean that you're earning
this regular payment because you have it
which makes it look a little bit more
like a security but in a completely
different way just like Bitcoin looks a
little bit like a commodity and a little
bit like a security but it's also
something completely different so again
what I said about earlier this is not
unregulated this is actually heavily
regulated but nobody has any idea
exactly how because the law is broad and
has harsh penalties and doesn't clearly
state whether something like that coin
would be in or out of one regime or in
or out of another regime and of course
it doesn't because the law was written
series law was written in the Great
Depression the definition of securities
hasn't changed much since then anyway
one more thing about the CFTC because
every
let's talk about see if you see it's fun
right CFTC has policing authority over
spot markets so if it finds evidence of
manipulation at coinbase or gemini or
what-have-you
it can still bring action against those
spot markets it just doesn't have
supervisory authority like the SEC has
supervisory authority over national
securities exchanges or like the CFTC
has supervisory authority over
derivatives markets so there is somebody
regulating for manipulation where they
find evidence of it even in commodities
spot markets but they don't get a live
data feed from the spot markets to prove
manipulation they have to find evidence
of it and then bring action against the
spot market because you know paintings
are very the Bitcoin currency of the of
the rich so it's lots of money
laundering is done with fine art and
real estate but what was the question so
why do you know the market affair of
paintings is not controlled by this
regulator it's a good question yeah
so again the spot markets you have a
Picasso I want to buy a Picasso we have
a transaction spot transaction are not
supervised by the CFTC and so art would
kind of be a commodity
except it's not fungible so I left out
something in the math everything that's
not a security is a commodity if it's
fungible if it's a unique object I don't
think it fits into the definition also
onions aren't commodities because they
got a carve out in the law if you look
at the definition of commodity it says
every all these things except onions
[Laughter]
fungible means one unit is the same as
any other unit whereas a Picasso of
course is quite special they've got
layers it's very strange
so the spot market in the Picasso
wouldn't be regulated and there aren't
liquid derivatives based on underlying
Picasso's if there were and they were
trading somewhere CFTC would regulate
that probably yeah I think so but at
least in the US and even in Europe now
that's that happens so slowly and so
these things apply now and they create
liabilities for people doing things with
them now that could be enforced and
Europe will probably change faster but
Congress is gridlocked over completely
unrelated matters and a political fight
that's getting increasingly ugly so
right and and I actually think sometimes
the way securities laws shuffle out is
not so bad a lot of particularly scammy
crypto currencies almost certainly do
fall into the debt
of security whereas I don't think that
coin does so it's actually very good
that then the Securities Exchange
Commission is they're going after I cos
that are basically just Ponzi schemes
but absolutely you things haven't
changed that radically there's just some
new wrinkles that might be deserving of
new laws and we can see how the existing
laws apply in the meantime and maybe
okay so I'm gonna go into this I don't
think we're gonna get to constitutional
law which is fine because this has been
a great discussion and I hope it's
useful but if you want to learn about
constitutional law of cryptocurrency
always happy to chat with you and we
have that paper as I said earlier so
this line between commodities and
securities is mostly whether you fall
into the definition of a security or not
that's the that's the main it's the same
qua non of who is your financial
regulator so what is security what is
the definition of security well it
basically boils down to two questions
that you'd asked about the asset being
traded one is the asset being sold as an
investment and two is there a person
upon whom investors are relying for the
value of that investment so the
intuition here is gold is sold often as
an investment and you don't really rely
on anyone for the value of gold you rely
on everyone
for the value of gold a massive market
of participants who are buying and
selling it miners who sometimes dig it
out of the earth faster sometimes slower
and you know users of gold like the
scientific research the dental industry
I guess at one point although not so
much anymore like all of this goes into
the price of gold where as a share of
Apple stock we really do obviously rely
quite centrally on whoever is running
Apple the company to determine the value
of Apple stock there are markets to but
this person and their board of directors
or whoever could issue a whole bunch
more shares they could completely change
the strategy of the company in a way
that would fundamentally weaken or
strengthen the value they could decide
we're not gonna make iPhones anymore
we're
now a cat cafe business I don't know if
you know so the two questions token
classification exercise we can go
through to talk about different crypto
currencies or icos or tokens is this why
do people want the thing do they want it
for its usefulness or for its value as
an investment and what's backing up that
value is it a network of people that's
extremely large like all the people
dealing with gold or is it really some
central person in the system the efforts
of others not the efforts of others
because that does that would in theory
be everything is dependent on the
efforts of others because we live in a
society damn it it's been determined as
the essential managerial or
entrepreneurial efforts of a third party
or promoter so yeah when the dental
industry decided to stop using gold for
fillings it might have hurt the price of
gold probably not but it might have but
was any of those persons doing something
whose essential managerial efforts
change change the value not really
there's lots of other people that use
gold for other purposes and lots of
other reasons that want gold than dental
fillings this may be a way of thinking
of it right it's hard my feeling is that
because it's open source and cuz there's
actually like some 600 contributors and
they've come and gone over the years in
fact the original person who wrote the
protocol just disappeared none of those
people are doing anything essential
they're doing things that are necessary
but they're none of them are essential I
think that's just my opinion man you
know
and it happens to be the opinion of the
relevant regulators in the SEC so far
but also that's just their opinion
ultimately because this is law and a
common law like test for what is the
security the final word would be a judge
and then it would get appealed and
appealed so the final word would be the
Supreme Court if it ever made it there
lots of fun not not for most people for
me because I'm perverse and a rent
seeker as a lawyer by definition so
investment versus utility I guess like
this is fairly obvious like putting
money into the thing what are you hoping
to get out more money or like cloud
storage like file coin is one very
widely publicized ICO and in theory
people want it for the storage but
actually a lot of people bought it
because they want it because they think
it'll be expensive in the future and
because you can't really go into the
minds of every purchaser cuz it would be
a nightmare as a legal standard where
the courts usually look is what are the
people selling it say did they ever say
that it would be more valuable than
they're in trouble if they really just
try to earnestly to say no it's really
just for use then maybe they're not in
as much trouble if you were versus
network again like PayPal works because
of some essential managerial efforts
Bitcoin I would argue oh this is just my
opinion works because of an unlimited
set of participants doing public key
crypto blockchain and competing to mine
and the software that allows them to do
that I don't think I think that's a
network not an issuer but this is law
not science not math again like Amazon
with cloud storage versus a network of
people providing cloud storage through
something like ipfs and file coin maybe
it's a network and not an issuer but so
now that we have this to question
classification exercise for tokens we
can graph things kind of in a really
sloppy non-scientific way so on the on
the x-axis I'm gonna put R on the y-axis
so I'm going to put why is this thing
valuable is it useful or is it an
investment because it's definitely a
continuum it's not like one like some
people use gold most people just want it
for value and here I'm gonna put Network
versus issuer what creates the value
because this is also a continuum in some
cases it's really just one guy in some
cases it's everyone and there's people
in the middle so this I think is useful
and this is actually how the case law
for securities works so you know Tim
Cook is definitely up here with shares
of Apple stock right people buy Apple
stock for money they don't take their
certificate and like try and make paper
airplanes out of it or something like
that and it really is Tim Cook and his
board of directors and that's what
people are relying upon over here and
maybe it's actually a little bit higher
because most people don't use gold but
some people do would be gold there's
really just a massive number of people
who dig gold out of the earth and so
it's there this might be things like oil
real estate up here are like member run
corporations it's kind of interesting
like where everybody who co-owns the
venture is also doing what the venture
does and these things are actually
traditionally not securities just like
commodities are not securities yeah all
the co-owners are there for investment
but they're part of the network you know
like they're there they are the ones
they rely on they're not relying on some
third party and then down here are
things like loyalty cards and golf
course memberships like you want it for
its usefulness you want to play golf
she's relying on whoever owns the golf
course to not issue too many memberships
because then the golf course gets
crowded or just you know you're relying
on the guy who owns the golf course to
not stop cutting the grass because that
would be a weird game of golf if it was
really long grass I've never played golf
but I'm assuming you can't play golf the
grass gets too tall
theater tickets might be here because
it's a bigger group of people that make
up a concert like worthwhile but maybe
they'd actually just be here I don't
know and this is interesting this is
like warehouse receipts for some
valuable item and I put this here
because I put all of these things here
because there are case law about these
things pre cryptocurrency so there's
case law that says that a fancy
apartment in Manhattan even if people
generally actually expect an investment
return the fact that you can live in it
is what makes it not a security there's
a case about golf course memberships
where somebody said you know most people
just want a membership because they want
a golf and that's why it's not a
security even though you're relying on
this person but there's another case I
think in New Jersey might be some Trump
ancestor maybe where somebody was
promising future golf courses that were
great tremendous golf course and they
were pre selling memberships to the golf
course to raise money to build it and
the court said you know actually this is
not a golf course in the traditional
quadrant here it's actually like up here
just people are expecting a return and
now there are tokens that do all of
these things and so actually we have a
lot of great case law maybe we don't
need to change the law it's not
satisfying to technologists though
because yeah there's case law that will
influence the court when they come for
your technology and maybe you'll be ok
it's very different than saying like you
were regulated by this not this but
there is a lot of good case law that
could ultimately make that determination
but it would shuffle out some way and
this one is interesting to me in light
of our stable coin conversation in that
the cases here are about receipts you
have this receipt and you can go to the
person who gave you the receipt and get
something and the cases where these
receipts were securities
we're ones where like there's one about
whiskey barrels where a guy was like
here's a receipt you all
the whiskey barrel I'm gonna hold it for
you and I'm gonna age it in my warehouse
and as it gets better with age because
that's how whiskey works you'll be able
to make money in the long run when you
come back and get your whiskey barrel
from me or what is more likely to happen
I will sell your whiskey barrel and give
you the profits when you want to get out
because you're not going to actually
like bring a truck up to the warehouse
and like carry a multi 500-pound barrel
so that was a security but at the same
time like having some legal document
that entitles you to assets in a trust
is not a security it's just custody of
something and like when you give your
car to the mechanic to be prepared and
he's holding it for you and you've got
like a receipt it's just called a
bailment in law you still own the car
they're just holding it for you the
receipt is not a security it's just
evidence of your continued to ownership
and their temporary custody of it so
there's like a whole range of things
here and those are the relevant cases
for things like stable coins where this
becomes tricky is some of them are more
like you get a dollar if you have a USD
see what we were talking about with
Libra there is some active management of
the assets that the receipt represents
two-thirds can vote to change what the
receipt represents so does that make it
more like an investment vehicle because
there's somebody who you're relying on
to keep the investment strong maybe but
this is again non determinative
it's just indicia and so yeah this is
I've never seen anyone else do this
graph but this is pretty much how the
case law works and so if we were to
graph what is the SE C's jurisdiction
this is probably something like this but
it could be more like that it could be
narrow and so we don't know yet we'll
find out I think I'll stop there
hopefully this has been helpful and
we're coming close to time and maybe we
can take a couple questions
[Applause]
so I guess I'll ask again so when you
kick too you know
this hour the second hour and
regulations it seems like you mostly
concentrated again I'm national yes but
when it comes to cryptocurrencies the
whole point is that it is international
and goes beyond national scope
unfortunately it's a pragmatic focus
because I don't see the global nations
giving up their sovereignty to protect
their own citizens to a global body and
so until that day happens it is national
laws that will apply and that is really
I'll admit very bad for the technology
because how can you run something when
you're subject to the laws of every
nation where you have users is it it's a
nightmare
and maybe that's more than anything else
more than any technical problems why the
banking system has remained as
fragmented as it has and why the payment
systems have remained as fragmented as
they are and maybe that's the only
reason why Bitcoin has gained a little
bit of traction is because it's finally
created a system that yes it's subject
to the laws of every jurisdiction but it
is powered by a bunch of people rather
than one person who could get hauled in
front of every jurisdiction so he's one
way to look at it it's a little bit
you know we have the Internet the
Internet is international facilities
also for to all sorts of transaction
business interactions right but it just
carries bits internationally right at
some point you know the service
providers people who are actually
building up the patients are the ones
who are subject to local so that would
be a sensible way to do it then right
because the Internet has generally
managed to work despite being global and
there being several regulators the
problem is the reason why I think that
worked in large part is because the
activity described is not one that was
regulated before in almost any country
at all in fact in the US if you try to
aggressively regulate that activity
which is just moving data from one
person to another you can't do that you
can't put a regulation in place because
it would be an impediment to free speech
which again we've got a paper on
constitutional law here which is
interesting whereas the activity within
payment systems is one that involves
trust and fiduciary responsibility to
not lose other people's money and that
is one that is regulated everywhere and
always was so whereas the internet just
had to fall into the lacunae of every
nation actually doesn't regulate this so
it's okay if you're regulated by every
nation anything dealing with holding
other people's money if you're doing it
on a global scale it's already regulated
in all those nations and so you're gonna
have to find a way through that and
people argue this people say like
bitcoin shouldn't be regulated at all
because the transaction messages on
Bitcoin are just speech they're just
data being moved around but we know it's
extremely consequential data and so even
despite my more civil libertarian
prejudices that I have in stin the first
hour I wouldn't go that far I wouldn't
say that like a Bitcoin transaction
message is speech and therefore can
never be ready
I think that's it's naive and probably
wrong
so I guess I'm getting the idea that
securities are defined by this upper
right quadrant and whatever but what is
the reason that that's how its defined I
my naive guess would be for example you
care about having an issue of verses in
that word because then there's someone
to blame or something like that yeah
it's a great question the securities
regulations evolved again in the Great
Depression in the US and then most
international securities regulations
just carbon copied that from the US with
some differences that actually make
their application narrower which is why
I think you've seen a lot of icos move
to Switzerland and places like that they
evolved for the specific purpose of
addressing what economists would call
information asymmetries that exists
between the promoter and the people who
buy things relying on the knowledge and
efforts of the promoter they've
basically said like it's okay if you're
convincing people to invest in a thing
and they're relying on you that's fine
we don't want to stop capital markets
from forming in fact the SEC has a dual
mandate protect investors and make for
efficient capital markets but if you're
going to be a trusted person you're
gonna have unique information like this
person knows how many shares they're
gonna issue and they know a lot of other
things and they also have a history and
the SEC is there to make sure that when
they issue something they make
disclosures of all that information and
so that's why they have to file an s-1
now inadvertently because once it's the
security you fall into the securities
regulations that also means that if it's
the security it can't trade on places
like coinbase because the securities
administrators exchange also regulates
national securities exchanges and ATSs
and only allows a set number of
participants to become 80s Azure
securities exchanges and has never
allowed any cryptocurrency companies to
be those exchanges so this
classification is the security seems
rational in some cases for a
cryptocurrency where you really are
reliant on the efforts of a few but it
would also destroy the viability of the
cryptocurrency
because there'd be no markets that trade
it and because individual use of it
would
be bogged down in a lot of compliance
it'd be as difficult to dispense of a
security digital currency as it is to
dispense of a share of Apple stock and
that makes it hard to work as a currency
we can talk more specifically offline
about why but so this is another
mismatch like maybe we could have some
kind of securities like regime where
disclosures are made but it can still
trade on markets that aren't securities
exchanges because otherwise it just died
but that would be new law
cool thank you guys
[Applause]